well meantime the dmv announcing it's  going to reopen its doors  on monday june 15th officials made the  announcement today during a virtual  press conference  now for the first 30 days the dmv  offices will be serving customers with  an immediate  need that's things like a private party  car sale maybe your driver's license was  suspended you don't have a valid form of  id  or a newly purchased car and you don't  have your license plates  what i want to be clear right from the  start  is that there is no most people to rush  right down on day one  we are going to be doing a phased  reopening we are going to be serving  those with the most  urgent needs first and asking others to  delay their visit for approximately 30  days or so  so again only customers and necessary  assistants such as maybe like a language  interpreter  are going to be allowed in the offices  when they do reopen  people will not be allowed to wait in  the lobby